taylor swift apparently a fan of of the
voice but she she said about you on that
show she said your weakness is musical
theater she thinks that your weakness as
a judge is musical
theater
boo who's that
it was the boo of someone with very low
blood sugar
[Laughter]
how do you respond to that criticism uh
truthfully yeah because i
there's certain i wouldn't like say it's
all musical theater but you know there's
that kind of one that kind that's like
this and yeah hey mr carruthers
kind of sorry i don't know what that
means but
it made me made her comfortable
sometimes so enthusiastic and yes and
everything and it kind of bugs me out a
little bit right so when she starts to
sing the songs from those types of
musicals it's like kryptonite
for me i can't do i can't deal with it
and she's saying a couple songs during
the voice shooting and she she put me on
the floor i couldn't even function right
so what you're basically saying is you
really don't like musical theater
certain aspects of musical theater conan
yes right i love book of mormon i saw
book of mormon as badass good morning
great
they're also making fun of musicals the
entire time too right so that's right
the reason why i loved it but if you see
a real earnest musical where people if
you went to cats let's see if cats even
still existed anymore
yeah i don't know i can't do it with the
musical i don't know
if someone's that
face
see yeah with the costumes yeah and the
costumes and i find i get very
uncomfortable uh uh when people you know
when they're singing with that level of
enthusiasm exactly i feel like i can't
match that enthusiasm
i feel like i can't deal with that
enthusiasm like it's not
like it's like it's not real enthusiasm
like it's like it's other things like
there's darkness there or something
right
i do it i don't feel like it's
genuine because i love a genuine i know
what you mean yeah have you ever have
you ever rushed the stage at a musical
and started punching people
not yet
not yet it seems like that's in you
though it seems like we're going to
trouble in river city that's for sure
[Laughter]
music man was a classic music man was
great but like les mis i feel like you'd
have to be physically restrained if you
went to les mis also very long very long
so it's a lot of it right all at once
right so it's a bad idea for anyone out
there in musical theater to get in your
face and start singing a song like
taylor did on the show
if you watch it it's unbelievable she
really did make me very sad and
uncomfortable but i i
i uh
blurbed for her next vow she made you
sad and uncomfortable made me sad and
uncomfortable adam levine adam levine
i actually went to go see les mis when i
was a kid and i remember very distinctly
with my grandmother and she
after the first act was i went to
pantages theater was les mis and i i was
so bored and sad and uncomfortable and i
remember asking if we could leave and
she took me to guitar center instead so
it was pretty awesome wow
i was i was 11. that's really good
that's a really good grandmother we can
go to guitars then she's from shoes from
new york and and we went to guitar
center and i took a guitar off the wall
and like of course it was like the most
expensive one i could get my hands on
and i was 11. i pulled down i started
playing it and you know this guy came
over and he was like sorry little man
like it's too expensive for you to play
and i was like i'll show you someday
i'll never forget that though
mr guitar center guy
it's like garth from wayne's world
sorry dude